all right everybody let's close out with
a Feelgood story we found online this is
what I'm
[Music]
liking a New York man is combining his
love of baking with his compassion for
kids to do something very wonderful he
sells these incredible cookies which
smell so good to send hundreds of sick
children and their families on dream
vacations to theme parks all over the
country super cool we have him on the
line right now from baking memories for
kids everybody say hello to Frank
watching on NBC
y what's up
GR so good to be on oh thank you oh my
gosh well we love having you and this is
such a beautiful thing you're doing so
this came from your own experience right
yes um I was out west hiking I found the
lump in my neck Kelly and I flew home
and I went to a bunch of doctors and I
had no idea they finally diagnosed it it
was Advanced stage three testicular
cancer and it was going into my brain so
I did three months of aggressive chemo
where I couldn't even walk up a flight
of stairs after a week but when I was
getting the chemo I saw moms and the
kids also getting chemo and suffering
and I knew if I was able to survive this
cancer God gave it to me for a reason
and I would be able to help families
going through what I went through and
more importantly the children a so
you're feeling good you're feeling good
now though I am so great and I started
the nonprofit baking memories for kids
and and we've been our 11th season
season so far Kelly
wow so how exactly does it work tell
everybody we bake cookies and i' I've
had a I have a swimming pool company
that I always used to bake these cookies
and give them to my customers and after
I got sick it was instead of making a
couple thousand cookies now we make
millions today we we've sold 4.1 million
cookies and we make them love Kelly on
the weekends and we sell them online and
all of that money goes towards funding
it's a weekl long amazing trip for the
entire family all expenses paid
Universal Studios every amusement park
and baking memories pays for the entire
trip that's incredible Frank thank you
so much wait I'm going to taste one
because well I
can oh my God love that it's
crunchy this is really good and I don't
usually eat cookies so thank
you thank you Frank you have such a
beautiful heart congrats on beating
cancer as well man that's what a
beautiful thing that you went through
something so tragic but you turned it
around to make it something beautiful
for others and yourself wow I'm loving
your post right
now well that's not all Frank our season
long partner pilot pin makers of precise
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
just like yourself so they're going to
be writing baking memories for kids a
check for $1,000 W awesome thank you so
much thank you so so much Frank have a
blessed holiday season thank you to all
our guests this hour to Raj P hingston
Matt Iceland Siller Mike Lauren fa and
the ters and O JL y'all have a great day
and if it's not try Chang
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home